let's do our big winners and so connor
would you like to lead us off are you
ready no i want to i want to kind of
dive in and digest everything that we
had here actually no we could talk it
out and we'll come up with our winners i
know i'm going to pick my winner and i'm
not going to take the jets just to make
everybody well aware of that i was going
to give you the job no no i want you if
you want the jets they're yours uh i'll
take the jets yeah well then why don't
you just do the jets and then we'll have
connor china i'll do the jets man are
you kidding me you look at the jets and
you look at what they're picking so
obviously it starts out because this is
a roller coaster right so we start out
with the jets and they they pick sauce
gardener feels good because you get the
number one corner and you get him after
another team took stingley but you're
still like we didn't really adjust the
thing that we wanted to address don't
worry you're going to come down here at
10 and you're going to get wilson okay
we got garrett wilson so we did address
that wide receiver spot we were able to
adjust the wide receiver spot okay that
feels good and then where's the where
the just like oh no we missed out on an
edge rusher it's not on the head dresser
don't worry coming down here pick 26.
germany johnson we got him we were able
to get these guys on they got all the
guy they got basically they got all the
guys they wanted yeah yeah they got
three possible top 10 picks on people's
boards yeah and like the only thing the
only thing that would have been even
more was if they were able to get one of
those top three offensive linemen
somehow but they they addressed
everything they wanted they got help for
zach wilson they got help for that ed
rush and they got the best corner in the
draft
they're winners they are big winners man
it's it's hard to disagree i mean you
love the maneuverability right to get
back into round one for a player they
had as a top 10 player in this draft a
player they would have taken at 10
but you know the deal when you're that
regime if zach wilson fails you fail so
you have to take garrett wilson who i
really love we love garewell's i think
he's the best receiver in the draft it's
awesome but there's a little part of you
that just goes man what about the edge
rush though and then to still walk away
with jermaine johnson that's really
really exciting for me
when i look at this draft just what the
eagles were able to do
talk about it conor we're all padding
you're just patting each other on the
back it's it's just unbelievable when
you look at
when you're trading for aj brown right
and that's the return it was 18 and a
very very late pick because you're
equipped what
it doesn't that doesn't make sense a guy
that's entering his prime and fits
everything you want to do he blocks his
butt off he can catch the ball down the
field he's angry runner with the ball in
his hands that alone to me made them the
winners but the way they navigated the
board to jump up and get
the
hulk right of the draft yes i mean
somebody that i literally called in the
comp a bigger vince
yeah and jordan davis and it is of all
the positions on the eagles it is the
one that they have shown over again that
they value the most they invest the most
into it and what he does for everyone
else keeping guys like hassan redick and
josh sweat a little bit more clean yeah
i'm curious to see the usage of him i'm
very curious to see how they use him i
know kelsey referenced the idea of using
him in multiple positions i'm very
curious to watch how he's used because
that's going to be the real key to the
value of that pick for me because if he
just drafted him to sit him inside
i don't know that's not a top 15 guy
yeah i don't know that i love it but if
you're going to move him around as
kelsey alluded to then i think you've
got an opportunity i think that's going
to be a really really fun one i'm
excited to see him evolve in
philadelphia i think that's a place you
go to evolve on the defensive line like
he mentioned with jonathan gannon he's
he'll experiment with the five yeah
and all that stuff so you did take
obviously mine uh i wrote down three
that also stuck out to me uh one being
kansas city leaving with mcduffie and
carloftus addressing both yes didn't
feel as juicy though then i wrote down
the ravens and i thought kyle hamilton
and linderbaum but then i went yeah but
they also traded their quarterback's
favorite wide receiver that can't be
happy and other than the eagles i'm
giving my big winner to the detroit
lions leaving here with aiden hutchinson
and jameson williams and your fight
you're getting aiden hutchinson who for
a team in the lions now you really have
your face of the franchise because it
ain't jarrod golf no so now aiden
hutchinson is your local boy that can be
dan campbell's you know prized
possession but you're also getting a
jameson williams guy that you partner up
with our dude amman monroe saint brown
but also whoever the next quarterback is
and heck guys they might get malik in
the third pick of this second round yeah
i don't know exactly what they had to
trade did they move it for jmo but then
they have two picks at the beginning of
this round so many moves but jameson
could be the guy for this quarterback or
the next quarterback i i love what the
lions did but i would i would be lying
if i told you
that the eagles are my big winner and
because i'm just in shock i'll seek one
more in i was gonna say i i got two more
you go you go the giants in there for
you i got the giants i love what the
giants did not i'll let felder kind of
run away with that in a second just to
get kayvon thibodeaux for your pass rush
and still get evan neal yes exactly the
giants what they've missed for so long
is a ground floor right they kept just
trying to put a roof over nothing by
paying kenny gallaudet a ton of money
paying a dory jackson a ton of money
just strange selections now they're
ground floor ground floor kayvon
thibodeaux can't build a house without a
foundation that that's it for the giants
this was a sure maybe not the most
glamorous but it's a smart effective
draft that's gonna get you back on track
in a two-year plan yeah i love that and
then i'm gonna go listen i'm gonna go to
my roots i'm gonna go to college
georgia
georgia
every single piece of recruiting
material that they put out for the next
year is gonna have five first rounders
on it it's gonna have five guys picked
in the top five guys picked in the top
32. five first rounders they're gonna
that's what's gonna be on there they're
gonna listen i'm sure tomorrow and i'm
gonna look for it i bet the promo tweets
are already out there because they're
like look at what you want to come you
want to be a champion come play for the
dongs you want to go to the nfl come
play for the dogs
yeah they're gonna go oh alabama how
many did you have oh you had two two oh
that's that's not five craziest thing
i know how felder feels about this the
second best georgia player in this draft
in my eyes only behind jordan davis is
going to be on the board when we're back
on the clock tomorrow guys yeah so can
we take a quick look at conor's big
board as we will be back tomorrow right
here on the br app and on youtube uh and
these are the best players available
according to conor's big board david
jabo still there nakobi dean is still
there the big defensive tackle out of uh
uconn travis jones is still there emma
kitay is there um and we did not see a
running back
uh no running back and no tight end
which if i have this right has never
happened in this era like going back
like 70 years or something we took a lot
of the winners so it's okay if our guys
uh steal some too let's go to richard
sherman first richard your your big
winner uh from this first round who
jumped out to you could be any team that
we've mentioned or haven't mentioned
or player
well i think it has to be derek stingley
i think it has to be derek singley i
think coming off of the injury coming
off a list frank injury to go number
three in the draft to be the first
corner taken um obviously tested
incredibly at his pro day i think he you
got to be jumping for joy you know
there's a lot of doubt there's a lot of
uncertainty when you're coming off the
injury you only play a few games you you
had a kind of up and down uh sophomore
year
so i think he has to be feeling like
feeling great about everything you know
i know the houston texans are happy and
excited to get him he's going to be a
big time play maker for him but he's my
he's my uh winner for today let's go to
omanra st brown he was busy early six
wide receivers taken in the first 18
picks but then we didn't hear from him
again i called your detroit lions a
winner who do you see as a winner player
or team
i'm gonna go with players so obviously
i'm gonna go with my guy drake london
winner for him being the first receiver
taken after having an ankle surgery you
know he had seizing ending injury i
think it was week eight or nine
appearing to be the first receiver
picked is huge for him
um you know atlanta's gonna turn things
in they got piss mariota so i think
he'll do just fine over there and then
one more i have to go with his kyle
hamilton on the ravens i know he got
picked later than expected but for him
that defense i think fits in perfect
like we talked about earlier you guys
talked about earlier a safety in that
defense in that division the the type of
offenses that that he'll see a lot of
running a lot of running the ball in
that that division so i think he's going
to thrive in that defense and i think
that's a perfect fit for him you talk
about players going to teams and as a
player you want to go to a team with a
perfect fit so yeah i think for kyle
hamilton that was the perfect fit for
him undoubtedly so and then we will wrap
it up with jason kelsey uh who him and i
were yelling at the top of our lungs
earlier uh who do you see as the big
winners whether it's a player or a team
yeah i mean i see the new york's is both
coming away with probably the biggest uh
nights for the most part on this i mean
joe douglas was extremely active able to
pull off a bunch of really solid moves
uh robert sal is an incredible defensive
coordinator he's added now
a lockdown corner and sauce gardener as
well as a premier edge defender which
will pair up nicely with some of the
other players they got up front um
new york evan neal was probably my
favorite pass blocking tackle they got
two solid tackles now
to add to an edge defender to go along
with those two monsters inside that they
have
um but
but i'll say this what an amazing night
what an amazing night because we got to
witness a bunch of people realize the
american dream a bunch of kids
are realizing the dream of playing in
the nfl and that's why the nfl draft is
so
freaking awesome man
it's it's it's incredible
it's an incredible moon for all these
kids and all their families and all
their hometowns and everywhere they've
been and um
but
only one team
got a certified dog in the nfl tonight
and that's the philadelphia eagles
so i don't think it's anywhere close my
man howie roseman was at work
and uh i'm ready to go to work
jason i couldn't understand the word you
were saying because i was watching porn
on this television and it was aj brown
highlights and i'm just sitting here
being like this guy is on the eagles
right now
unbelievable man
what a night